documentaries do we talk about don't
[ __ ] with cats we've been talking about
Luka Magnotta on here for I know but did
you see don't [ __ ] with cats is that one
oh my god you see it I know we know
about it
I know you know about it I know we
talked about it but it's not it's still
watching it it just makes it just so
much more visceral like more depraved so
much depraved basically I wanna it's
been out for a while so [ __ ] it's
about Luka Magnotta some Canadian skinny
white dude who idolized American Psycho
yeah but he also wanted to become an
actor and beget begin to show business
without the talent and he would audition
for things couldn't get anything because
he just doesn't have it and so then he
is so narcissistic and evil and
psychopathic that he started killing
cats online so he would he'd the first
one was he put two kittens in a plastic
bag and the suck the air out of the
[ __ ] bag and he put it online it's
like streaming on live leak or something
yeah live leak and then a group of you
know just enthusiasts out there not a
cat killing enthusiasts but people that
are there love cats yeah started um
dining together on Facebook and trying
to investigate and trying to find this
guy and then he drowned a cat as well
his identity had not been exposed I
don't want to get completely into it
because I want people to watch it if
you're and I'm gonna say this because I
know Marc Maron loves his cat he just
lost a cat and I've been telling him to
watch it I said it twice you gotta watch
it he's like so the cat stuff they don't
show it in the document of this show
that the beginnings of a picture and
that's the part I couldn't even like
it's very difficult to watch it's very
difficult to watch this guy is a piece
of [ __ ] human garbage he really is
and if I've tried to be violent right
but there's if there's a hell he is
there's a special
for this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] but you
also then realize that it runs deep and
his mother is just as [ __ ] crazy oh
yeah you don't behave like that without
you know I mean a past you know and his
mother is a [ __ ] witch let's just put
a Canadian Lich let's just say that does
he kill a human at some point yes [ __ ]
not remember if it's there he is that
story and so well he puts out you know
in an ad on Craigslist that I'm shooting
a movie and this Chinese guy answers it
it makes me so angry because sorry but
he you know I'm gonna see something very
controversial and don't blush yeah put
it down like your feather pens yes so
you know a lot of people online on
Twitter or whatever have said you know
how come people are more mad about in
the cat's and not the Chinese about that
night right because the cats didn't have
any [ __ ] options didn't choose to be
there all right answer an ad like Oh
looking for cats for no no yeah yeah and
it cat did it like all hey yeah yeah I
want to be in your short film Yeah right
whatever right but it's like I haven't
been I haven't been in a lot of movies
I've been in a few lists yeah you asked
for a script
no baby may you rest in peace no I am a
you rest in peace and what you do what
happened to you right but there are some
things that he should have done
cautionary tale a cautionary ayah if you
don't get a movie off of you know me and
Craigslist sure number one but it I
think that he responded to it more as
knowing that there would be a chance for
like a hookup
that's the way I read it Oh sexual man
yeah there was some sexual innuendo
there he was like okay he was probably
trying to you know meet somebody which
is like so many people do that we do
that whole day every day you're eating
apps and whatnot yeah it's terrible I
don't know why I said that because it's
parents oh it's awful oh boy why say
that don't cut it out what did you guys
do for Christmas